magic mystery and Mayhem oh my from
sentient swords and CIA conspiracies to
warring martial arts academies the world
of the movie ninja is as vast as it is
weird
for most American audiences the term
ninja summons up a collection of Pop
Culture references the long-running
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles franchise
and Chris Farley's Prat Falls in Beverly
Hills Ninja maybe a couple that come to
mind for cult movie fans it may be the
Avalanche of interchangeable 80s action
movies featuring a mix of Caucasian and
Asian actors tossing shuriken at bad
guys
thank you
it's very impressive
but the earliest movies about Ninja long
predated the 80s boom Japanese
filmmakers first began making movies
about Ninja as early as the silent film
era many of these early titles centered
around folk tales like those of terria
and sarutobi Sasuke and yes these
stories directly inspired the Naruto
characters of the same name
unfortunately like the vast majority of
silent movies very few of these early
efforts still exist in fact the 1921
film Jiraiya the brave is considered to
be the oldest surviving ninja film
though only 20 minutes of the movie
remain intact today ninja are seemingly
everywhere when ninja went worldwide in
the 1980s other countries started making
their own Adventures including Sweden
Argentina South Korea and India there
are ninja anime giant monster movies
comedies and even adult only films ninja
were inescapable in Japanese movie
theaters during the 1950s and 1960s the
website vintage ninja breaks down this
period into distinct types with one
being the fantasy fueled efforts these
ninja were more like Wizards battling
evil Sorcerers and giant monsters with a
mix of swordplay and spells the 1959
animated ninja film Shonen saratogi
Sasuke fits in this vein as we witness
the titular Proto ninja and his fight
against a lake demon unlike many of its
fellow fantasy ninja films it saw a
theatrical release in the United States
but strangely the American version
called magic boy removed any references
to ninja the other ninja films of the
60s boom included black and white
historical action dramas fueled by a mix
of political Intrigue energetic camera
work and bloody fight sequences some
traits such as the Ninja's superhuman
stealth and their array of unique
weapons would carry over into the brawny
American cousins of the 1980s but films
like the Stark psychologically driven
Samurai spy couldn't be more different
from the action Antics in the American
Ninja series
for many westerners their first exposure
to ninja came from the 1967 James Bond
film You Only Live Twice it focuses on a
dissolute Bond learning Ninjutsu in
Japan to carry out the assassination of
his Nemesis blofeld the firing power
inside my craters enough to annihilate a
small army
you can watch it all on TV
two real-life martial artists were hired
by The film's Producers to lend
authenticity to the ninja sequences Judo
Champion Don F Traeger not only trained
Sean Connery in many fighting styles but
also served as stunt double this wasn't
uncommon as Draeger had previously
served as John Wayne's stunt double in
the 1958 film The Barbarian and the
Geisha the other consultant was Masa Aki
hatsumi recognized today as a Grand
Master of the nine schools of martial
arts who also appeared in the movie as
an aid to the Spy tiger Tanaka atsumi
later used his training to found a dojo
in Japan where thousands travel each
year to learn Ninjutsu techniques
by the mid-1970s ninja had infiltrated
American pop culture they appeared on
television series like Kung Fu and
Hawaii 5-0 while Marvel and DC
introduced Ninja characters in Judo
Master Shang Chi Master of Kung Fu and
the deadly hands of kung fu Anthology
however ninja wouldn't turn up in a
Hollywood movie until 1975's the Killer
Elite directed by action autor Sam
pekinpaw the movie concerns a pair of
undercover agents for hire played by
James Khan and Robert Duvall their
testosterone fueled friendship comes to
an abrupt end when Duvall double crosses
Khan and leaves him for dead Khan's
Rehabilitation involves intense martial
arts training which serves him well when
he hits the Revenge Trail to stop an
assassin from killing a Taiwanese
politician this doesn't sit well with
Duvall who summons a small army of ninja
to finish the job but peckinpaw's ninja
are no more effective than standard
issue henchmen falling hard to a guy
with a cane a dumpy Bert young a
middle-aged diplomat and his daughter
and a machine gun toting Bo Hopkins
according to the martial arts compendium
these fists break bricks the early 1980s
ninja were thriving on TV and
best-selling books and even in perfume
the time was right for a Hollywood Ninja
movie and Mike Stone thought it would be
his ticket to stardom Stone a karate
champion and instructor pitched a ninja
movie called Dance of Death to the Canon
group the movie Factory that would be
responsible for many of Chuck Norris's
action titles with stone signed on as
both star and scriptwriter the producers
were hoping to beat 20th century Fox's
adaptation of Eric Van lustbaders the
ninja to theaters they didn't need to
worry that production fell into
developmental Health but they soon faced
their own problems with the movie that
would become 1981's Enter the Ninja
producer manahim Golan reportedly
arrived on set and fired the director
crew and stone as leading man as Stone
said in the Canon film guide Volume 2 in
hindsight there was no way I would ever
be the leading man in any movie Golan
stepped in as Direct after and hired
Italian actor Franco Nero to replace
Stone Gentlemen let's be reasonable why
don't we talk
Golan would eventually walk back his
decision somewhat rehiring Stone as
flight coordinator and as Nero stunt
double he allowed Stone to hire his own
stuntmen including a Japanese Kendo and
Judo champ named shokosugi kosugi would
also play one of the film's bad guys a
performance that made him the face of
ninja throughout the 1980s
throughout the 80s shokosugi was an
on-screen murder machine laying waste to
every bad guy who dared to cross his
path one of his most popular movies
during this period was 1985's pray for
death that was the best you could hope
for from show that he'd kill you quickly
that image contrasted heavily with
kosuki's real life as a hard-working
family man with a healthy skepticism
about his status as an action hero
though his on-screen characters made him
exceptionally popular his legacy was
ultimately cemented as the first
Japanese actor to top Bill an American
action movie while he had been elevated
from the bad guy and entered the ninja
to the hero in Revenge of the Ninja he
was dismissive of the loopy Ninja 3 the
domination and left the Canon group over
a contract dispute after pray for death
earned an x-rating he requested cuts to
ensure that younger fans could see it
when the national box office returns for
ninja movies cooled off kosuki hosted
the ninja theater VHS series and
eventually returned into Japan where he
found new fame on television in 2009 the
wachowskis paid tribute to his early
screen Days by casting him as the
villain in Ninja Assassin though the
Canon group lost shokosuki they still
saw money to be made in the shuriken and
Katana business as noted in these fist
break bricks the company pre-sold
American Ninja as a vehicle for Chuck
Norris they had to go looking for a new
action star though as Norris wasn't
interested in the project enter Michael
dudekoff a model turned actor who often
played affable boyfriends and best Pals
in movies and on television
deal per what's this word
parmesan director Sam Furstenberg was
instantly smitten with dudikoff
recalling to Kung Fu magazine.com it was
like who this is the American Ninja the
way he talked the way he behaved his
body language everything but dudikoff
locked was the necessary martial arts
skills he knew some but he wasn't
entirely believable as someone who could
fight multiple Ninja at once or jump out
of a helicopter thankfully The Producers
still had Mike Stone on hand to
choreograph the fights and helped udakov
achieve Ninja level prowess it certainly
didn't hurt that he was paired up on
screen with Steve James a Brawny
real-life martial artist dudikoff would
play Joe Armstrong in two of the three
sequels cheering lead billing with actor
David Bradley on American Ninja 4. let's
say it's 1982 and you're an independent
distributor with a sizable catalog of
martial arts movies audiences aren't
lining up for these titles like they
used to not like the new crop of ninja
flicks cleaning up in theaters and on
home videos so being the enterprising
type you snip off the title card cards
from a handful of your movies and Stitch
on new ones that prominently feature
ninja the fact that your movies have
little or nothing to do with Ninja well
that's beside the point according to a
1986 New York daily news interview with
Rod Hurley vice president of Master Arts
video the joke is you put the word ninja
in the title and you can sell a couple
thousand extra copies one of the more
amusing examples includes 1982's Shaolin
Prince When it finally arrived on
American VHS it poured the title death
mask of the Ninja despite no ninja being
in the film The 1978 period action drama
Heroes of the East features Chinese and
Japanese martial arts but its real
concern is a broken marriage
nevertheless it was renamed numerous
times given titles such as Shaolin
challenges ninja challenge of the ninja
and Shaolin Vs ninja
when a film subgenre runs out of gas one
of the most common ways for producers to
retain fan interest is to fold elements
of other genres into their titles this
cross-pollination has resulted in some
inspired hybrids and some genuine
Oddities and ninja movies are no
exception
[Music]
during this period fans would stumble
across mutations like 1989's robot Ninja
a no budget comedy about a comic book
artist fighting crime Ninja Academy from
the same year applied the police academy
formula to a pair of rival ninja schools
populated by a misanthropic weirdos of
course the hands down winner for most
bizarre ninja hybrid movie might just be
1984's Ninja 3 the domination intended
as another sequel to enter the ninja the
film takes an unexpected turn into the
supernatural Lucinda Dickey is an
aerobics instructor possessed by the
spirit of an evil ninja James Hong is an
exorcist who fails to remove the spirit
which prompts who else shokosugi to step
in floating swords Lycra bodysuits and
mind control all combined into a truly
absurd experience while it's unlikely
that the American made ninja movies of
the 1980s will ever be described as
Classics even the worst Canon group
titles can appear worthy of the
Criterion Collection action when
compared to the films of Hong Kong's
Godfrey hoe he flooded International
markets with hundreds of cheaply made
nonsensical ninja movies during the
1980s and 1990s
all right you better cut out now
oh I think we better do what he says
after catching wind of Enter the Ninja
and wanting his own Franco Nero for his
ninja projects hoe would hire American
actor Richard Harrison a star of
spaghetti westerns however hoad didn't
seem to care that Harrison didn't know
martial arts he also didn't care that
the props and sets were Dollar Store
quality or that the movie's dialogue was
seemingly endless verbal loops on ninja
Empires hose simply hit his stunt
players behind hoods and masks and threw
in plenty of Gunplay and smoke bombs to
hide the seams but what set hoe's movies
apart from other low-budget martial arts
titles of the era was his practice of
recycling footage from one film to
create dozens of others scenes of
Harrison shot for one movie would turn
up in several other hoe titles and
Harrison later claimed that hose movies
caused him to quit acting completely
when ho exhausted his footage of
Harrison he bought movies from other
Asian markets and dissected them for
more Frankenstein Creations quality more
lack thereof didn't stop ho until he
supposedly retired in the early 2
thousands to become a film teacher of
all things
in the 1980s ninja exploitation films
wreaked low budget Havoc across
International screens in the Philippines
Hong Kong turkey and even India but one
probably wouldn't expect a ninja movie
to come from Sweden however the
Scandinavian country produced a small
handful of homegrown ninja titles in the
late 80s with the best known to
International audiences being 1984's the
ninja Mission
and listen good
you're to take the ninja into Russia and
get back off out a hopelessly convoluted
and astonishingly gory Thriller that
pits a cia-backed team of Swedish ninja
against Soviet forces that hold a
defecting Russian scientist hostage Beau
F munta the self-described grandfather
of European Ninjutsu co-stars is a
member of the Ninja team whose martial
arts skills could be charitably
described as rudimentary however their
ability to kill bad guys in as messy a
manner as possible is top-notch director
Matt's Helga Olson had previously made
headlines in the early 80s for producing
the historical epic Sweden for the
swedes which landed him in prison for
accounting misdeeds he rebounded with
the international theatrical and VHS
sales for the ninja Mission which he
followed with a slew of other action
titles each one as technically inept yet
enthusiastically made as the next
the VHS boom wasn't just a fresh Revenue
source for theatrical movies old and new
it also provided aspiring filmmakers a
chance to get their homemade Productions
out into the world these backyardo tours
typically focused on the genres that
attracted the widest viewership so if
you owned a headband and a rubber
throwing star this was your chance to be
in the Ninja movie business some of the
best known or notorious home ground
ninja titles included Justice ninja
style a 12 000 actioner by St Louis
detective turned filmmaker Ron White and
La Street Fighters where a 40-something
former Bruce Lee clone plays a high
schooler battling drug dealers but Ellie
Street Fighters director Richard Park Wu
sang also oversaw another amateur ninja
picture Miami Connection that
inexplicably found in enthusiastic
audience three decades after its
original release according to park after
seeing an interview with Taekwondo
Studio owner Master YK Kim on a South
Korean talk show Park pitched him on
making a martial arts movie Kim
recruited his students as cast members
Road money from friends and even
mortgaged his school to fund the movie
however Distributors took one look at
its plot a mishmash of non-sequiturs
about a rock band running a foul of drug
dealing ninja and advised Kim to just
throw it away flush forward to 2009 when
Alamo Drafthouse programmers Zach
Carlson bought the film on eBay and
screened reel for audiences at their
Austin Texas location rapturous response
led to Festival dates leading Kim
baffled delighted and ready to make more
movies he told weekly we have planned to
produce one top quality action film with
modern philosophy every three years
Taiwanese actor John Liu earned a
following for his superhuman high kicks
in low budget Hong Kong and Taiwanese
kung fu movies during the 1970s but as
the old joke goes what he really wanted
to do was direct in the 1980s he
established his own micro budget
production company and wrote produced
directed and starred in four nearly
incoherent martial arts movies the last
of these New York ninja began filming in
1984 but was abandoned after its
distributor filed for bankruptcy this
drove Liu to give up filmmaking and
return to Paris to oversee his own
martial arts studio
no you can't
be me I mean Flash Forward three decades
and the film preservation and Home Video
distributor vinegar syndrome locates the
surviving elements but no script or
storyboards when Leo declined to
complete the movie editor Curtis M
spieler painstakingly assembled the
footage into a semi-coherent storyline
earning himself credit as the film's
redirector after corralling several cult
actors to dub the on-screen characters
New York ninja played the film festival
circuit in 2021 eventually receiving a
national release as for the finished
product well seeing really is believing
audiences may not fully accept the sight
of a ninja vigilante patrolling New York
City occasionally on roller skates in
search of the cartoonish gang members
who killed his wife a radioactive
villain called the plutonium man and an
army of grade school Ninja fans also
factor into the mix which wobbles and
Bops to a new 80s synth style score by
Voyager
though ninja appeared to be unstoppable
on screen their appeal eventually waned
while remaining a popular draw in the
Home Video Market theatrical returns
began to dwindle as the 80s Drew to a
close a wave of negative press started
about how ninja led to real-life crime
including a highly publicized 1984 home
invasion of actress director Penny
Marshall profit-minded producers began
shifting away from Ninja with films like
1985's no retreat no surrender elevating
the Marquee status of kickboxing a more
aggressive combat sport than Ninjutsu
with less spirituality with the help of
the energetic Belgian martial artist and
actor Jean-Claude Van Damme kickboxing
and mixed martial arts came to dominate
the American action scene introducing a
host of new movie stars these ranged
from Steven Seagal and Bruce Lee's son
Brandon to direct video players like
Billy Blanks Dawn the dragon Wilson and
Cynthia Rothrock
[Music]